who do you doing we're recording all
right everybody we've got five book
announcements that I want to quickly go
over and I really need your feedback on
number five okay so we're getting close
to book release date it's it's finally
happening i'm so excited december six is
the book launch we're almost there I
can't believe that this two-year process
is finally it's finally good again since
i started writing the book yeah it's
been crazy it's nuts it's it's finally
gonna be released I can't believe it
feels like it feels like the thing
that's never gonna get out there it
feels like I've just destined to torture
myself I keep waiting for something but
it's actually gonna happen my voice
cracked as I said that so I'm pretty
pumped at what are you reading this is
the killer look at the audience let's
believe nation they want to see you I
wanted to record this video multiple
times earlier but my first update is
that I might have the first hardcover
version in front of me and Nina wouldn't
let me write my giannina would let me
open the package without her no yeah
most multiple time you are busy I'm
always ready but you wouldn't let me
open this without you you asked me if I
want to be in there I say yeah but
there's a catch am i yelling no you
didn't say can you do it on you oh can I
get on my own walk today so we are here
about to open what might be the first
version of my book that's the first
announcement why don't you open it there
you go open it use your powerful mean
arms use my muscle power Felina muscles
here they are is it is it it is it oh
wow look at that I know it's a hard
coverage the very first hardcover
version all right said I'm so excited I
didn't think I was gonna be it oh my god
this is very typical no no no we need to
be careful with this okay don't want to
see the scissors
okay where the scissors this is it holy
cow I wonder if the author will sign it
for me he will sign it for me for sure
because I'm very nice what's that look
one what I'm running pay attention I'm
so excited that's it guys look at that
the happy with the bedsides i think yes
one day throwing not happy with the look
can we see it his focus too much light
see the bent sides I'm happy about that
but look at that look at that that they
start sure so this is amazing look at
that well who's that guy yeah wow this
is a good looking book I'm so excited
this is the first one oh look at the
side home look at that look at the spine
guys look at the spine Wow just taking
it in I like the arrow good tiara yeah
cuz i'm watching aironet no this is the
first version this is a collector's
edition right here I could take away
this this is also a collector's edition
this is that the softcover that is never
going to be released and now we get the
official hardcover that stands on its
own let me take a ticket we're down
disappoint you want to read this on the
subway yeah has to be put in a frame or
something you have a lot more I have 10
yeah they're all my children they're
very special okay yes so gets released
december six it comes out december
stakes i think it gets shipped december
six so if you bought that if you bought
the book book it gets shipped december
six and i don't know how long thinks if
you got prime or however long it takes
to go and if you get the audio version
or the e-book version I think it's just
you have it it's on your device so
excited okay that's the person else for
ya and that
work okay second is we updated the
website we have a brand new website for
the book local entrepreneur Joshua help
me put it together and mobile friendly
we get a lot of complaints from people
about the website not being mobile
friendly so this one is mobile friendly
it's simpler and i'm a fan so you can go
check it out Evan Carmichael calm / one
word and I'd love to know what you guys
think of it if you have any problems
with it any feedback you have really
appreciate that so that's the second
ones to what the new website number
three we've been getting and number five
is why need your feedback on so stick
around number three is the book is now
available in the UK and in India a lot
of you guys were asking how do I get it
in India how do I get it in the UK so if
you go to Amazon or whatever the
websites are that you typically go to
butts if it's it's definitely on amazon
UK and india so you can pick that up
which is awesome my publisher wrote to
me to say hi I'm Anna ho ball as well
just wanted to share the good news that
we've released the book in all formats
so it means hardcover version in audio
version in the UK in India that means
that the North American edition will be
available to consumers there through
amazon and other retailers so it's
official from the publisher a lot of
people are asking for india in UK so
it's done the fourth one is we found a
source for people who want to buy
international orders for those of you
who've been asking to buy from other
countries that don't have it that are
not endear UK they wrote to tell me
about a place called bookdepository.com
that they uploaded it to that has free
international shipping as well so you
can check that out they wrote I Evan you
might try Book Depository calm they ship
anywhere for free we're getting the book
uploaded now they're behind them their
fee but it's up now so you guys can
check out Book Depository calm and you
can check out the book there as well if
you want free international shipping so
it should be available everywhere now
I'm still looking at it you know what I
want to see didn't ask me what it looks
like without the cover on because when I
you should read a book sit beside them
but that's safe that look okay black and
white alike that but
look at that yeah it's nice i like guys
look at that look at the gold huh looks
like a Bible well didn't ask me about
this but I like it yeah look at that
that's that's some pretty special thing
did you wash your hands before you know
I use the bathroom in an even wash my
hands ticking that's really collector's
edition okay and number five when I need
your what I need your feedback on what I
wanted to feedback on was what do you
want to see what the continuation of
this series so at the start the Evans
book serious about me writing a book and
everything I had to go through to get
the publisher and to deal with the
publisher and get it up and all of the
all of the things around writing the
book and my process and you guys joined
with me on that journey then it evolved
into how is marketing the book and
creating the website and doing deals and
interviews and my process for basically
marketing and getting exposure for the
book and and now the book is going to
come out right so december six is not
that far away and i have to decide what
do we do with this series in the future
this couple options one we could not
continue and i do a new series on the
channel something else too i could
continue the series and talk about how
i'm continuing to market it and other
ideas that happened with the book and
things that are going on with it and
updates on sales and whatever new
adventures are happening in the world of
the book and three I could do what I've
been thinking about doing is a is a
study group for the book and doing a
once a week hang out with you guys
who've bought the book and go through it
together one chapter at a time so i
think there's seven chapters in the book
so for seven weeks we'll do a chapter a
week and so you guys all read chapter
one come hang out with me for half an
hour let's talk about chapter one and
then next we come back with new chapter
to chapter 7 and then maybe a bonus
session at number eight have a guest on
or something and then repeat the cycle
either stop at a repeat the cycle so um
those
the things I'm toying with I'm kind of
playing around with my head so do we
canceled the series and do something
totally different do we keep updating
you on what's going on with the book do
you want the self study group or do you
have a different idea that you'd love to
see around the book for this time slot
after december six and it's out so let
me know really really really look
forward to hear your feedback your
thoughts or suggestions leave it down
the comments what do you work are you
looking at what's happening you're tired
I woke up a six this money yeah you're
cute though we have a couple questions
from previous videos and I want to
respond to Nina's Nina grew then it's
take it off okay hugs whoa joke okay
couple questions and I get back to
number 165 drums when you wrote the book
did you go for hours at a time just
writing or do you believe in setting the
timer for 30 minutes and taking five
minute breaks in between so whenever I'm
in the middle of something really
creative whenever I'm in kind of the
zone of creating creating creative work
I hate being interrupted I hate it I
don't want to take breaks when I was
doing the audiobook I didn't want to
break I didn't want to break through the
bathroom I didn't want to break to eat I
didn't want to break to do anything I
wanted to use be there and create and I
was working with a team so I think about
them too and like okay maybe these guys
want to go home where these guys have to
eat lunch or go to the bathroom so yeah
we work mostly around their schedule not
me wanted the break same thing with
writing when I was in the zone writing I
blocked off my entire Tuesday afternoon
to write because I can't write in 30
minute junks I could write an article uh
you know a guest post for something I
could do that or a newsletter sell
something contained but for the book
because it was so big and I need to keep
track of my head of where everything was
going the first half an hour was the
right off right I'm right off like that
it wasn't super productive and then I
got into it and I wanted to stay there
as long as I possibly could and so I
would not i would i would limit as my
brakes as much as possible i definitely
did not set a timer and
gonna work for half an hour it was I'm
going to junk off my entire afternoon
and get as much as I possibly can um now
I try doing something like that what I
tried to eyes and you know I'm gonna
wake up but every day do 30 minutes in
the morning eat my breakfast and then
write some write a new page or two for
the book it's just stuck that's not how
I work it's not part of my work process
I need huge chunks of time and if I ever
do another book it's gonna likely be the
same thing where I just dedicate an
entire day to write in the book and then
doing my other stuff for the rest of the
week what I haven't tried and I don't
know how well it would work that some
authors do do is they just take two to
three weeks totally off go somewhere in
the mountains and just write the book no
distractions and just go all in I think
I like having the break in between I
like being able to kind of reflect on it
and come back to it but I don't know the
process work pretty well for me and
we'll see we'll see the book 2 comes out
we'll see we'll see what the process is
like maybe we'll do this all over again
for book to relaxing sleep station Evan
you mentioned sharing a link if i was to
post one link to all my friends and
family that I could be proud of that
spreads your message about the book the
way you want it to be spread which video
which you want shared if it doesn't yet
exist perhaps you can make that video
that's a great question thank you I
think the easiest page if I had one link
to send it to it wouldn't be to a video
would be to the landing page for the
book the one that we just finished and
launched the new version of so that'd be
a great one if you go to the pre-sale
page there there's a list of different
videos that talk about the book and
links to a playlist where you can find
different book videos of either excerpts
of the book or me talking about the book
I would encourage you to share the one
that you feel most fits like what that
speaks to you there's somewhere I'm
being interviewed and I'm talking about
the book and you see the kind of genuine
passion coming out and some examples
there's some that's more on a
motivational side and it's me reading
some
from the book and so you can get a sense
of what it's like in the book from that
whatever whatever you feel is a touches
you the most i love it also whatever
touches you the most because if you like
it then chances are your friends will
like it too and and I really just to
take a step back and really appreciate
the support I really appreciate the
willingness to share and help out um I
really like all you guys really really
means a lot to me and I'm so excited to
get this into your handsome i Miha bill
cool stuff Evan will audio book we sold
separately or you get a download access
if you buy physical copy it's sold
separately that's not in my control I
would love to have done bundles um I
have different package deals and bonus
offers but it's not really the way that
the industry works at least with my
publisher and so super restricted on
that the hardcover book comes with a
whole bunch of bonuses actually all the
book offers that I do I'm making my own
bonuses as a result of like the
publisher not having bonuses so I'm
making my own bonuses that if you email
in your receipt you'll get the various
bonuses and if you buy more books you
get bigger bonuses and access to me and
coaching and that kind of stuff but the
hardcover book is the hardcover book
that's that's what it looked like plus
all the bonuses i give you the e-book i
think is an option where there's an
enhanced version where there's video so
i recorded 45 minutes ish i don't
remember exactly a video that's
complementary to the book where after
each chapter i talk about what's going
on the important points to remember a
little extra insight for me on video
that is only available if you have
bought the deluxe ebook version and then
the audiobook version there's no bonus
except for the bonuses that i give but
but it's me right like I'm reading it
it's pure fire I had a ton of fun doing
it bought a ton of energy to it and I
think you know I bought books I bought
audio books where the author didn't read
it and I was really let down I'm sure
the voice actor whoever was on there you
know did their best but it's different
when
from the actual author it's different
when you're buying from the entrepreneur
themselves and you get a little bit of
their time and attention you know I
spoke it like I wanted it to be read
right I spoke it like I was thinking it
as I wrote it and I don't think that
anybody else can kind of get inside my
head to do that and so I think that in
itself is a bonus because a lot of
people a lot of authors just mail at it
and they don't want to do the e-book I
didn't want to do the audiobook they
don't want to do the voice recording
because it takes too much time yeah but
if you want the audiobook and you want
the hardcover then it's two different
purchases and it's not like I make
nothing from a book so I have no control
over that stuff but yeah thank you for
the question with Avilan I appreciate
the support dawid last question Thank
You Evan for your effort will you have
Russian translation of your book so
that's a great question thank you the
way that that works is sought to start
know at the start it's only in English I
destructed any we want to do an audio
version and it was you guys who said hey
we want an audio version we wanted audio
versions with it okay we're doing an
audio version and then even have an
audio version be available in presale is
super rare usually it's only the e-book
version and the even the e-book version
with deluxe with videos is not common
for a first-time author but because you
guys kept asking forth and that led to
the creation of the deluxe ebook version
and the audio version the way that it
works in is it's based off of sales is
based off of interest so if we're
getting a lot of people who are
interested in Russia then it will be
translated into Russian and the same for
any country you know they're looking at
total sales numbers and you know where
they're coming from and in the US and UK
and Australian canada english speaking
countries obviously the easiest market
because it's english-speaking but
already for getting a lot of English
sales in a country then it makes sense
as a hey we're getting English sales
here what if we translate it to that
language we can get even more sales and
reach more people and touch more lives
that is not in my control at all it's
really up to the publisher except what i
can do is help push the price
if you guys keep saying hey we want this
in Russian and the sales are okay in
Russia that's extra ammunition so every
time you guys say heaven can this happen
can this happen can this happen I
forward it off to my publisher and that
helps light a little bit more of a fire
so if you guys want in your language or
one in your country and you can't find
it or you know want something else fit
into the book let me know leave in the
comments I forward it all onto the
publisher and that helps them to take
action so I'm going to end it there guys
it's a it's it's awesome thank you for
joining me for this i'm so glad that was
actually the book i was nervous i had
this here for a week and and i wasn't
sure what was actually inside if it was
the real book or not so it's i'm just
gonna look at it for a while just gonna
have it there and yeah anyway so let me
know about the answer to my fifth
question about the future of this series
what you would love to see really really
appreciate that leaving the comments
below and as usual for the next couple
weeks if you have any questions about
the book or my book writing process
leave in the comments and i will answer
you in next week's video thank you guys
so much for all the support it's been
incredible along this journey and i
can't wait for it to continue with you
guys and and hear the feedback and
answering your questions and guide you
through the process it really really
means a lot to me so I appreciate that
so I believe in you guys I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love guys
I'll see you soon